fault new vegas is now when it will most
likely be for the foreseeable future my
favorite fallout game of all time while
i started my journey of fallout with
fallout 3 around 2010 it was new vegas
that really hooked me in going from the
capital wasteland to las vegas to me
felt like a bold choice vault 3 was
known for that gritty and rustic
atmosphere you really felt like you were
in the wasteland and with the
possibility of the las vegas strip being
included i was eager but skeptical to
hop into the game i remember questioning
why bethesda back then wasn't making
this but not only did i not cares i just
wanted to play fallout again i would
soon realize it was one of the best
decisions that could have ever made as
it led to the most unique fallout game
at the time while it's similar
mechanically to fallout 3s both were a
part of the same engine it's clear lots
of aspects of new vegas were very
different this is also seen as both an
introduction and an homage to black
isle's past work referencing factions
characters and plots only seen in those
original games it was a breath of fresh
air for multiple reasons and its core
was another fallout game and i was
perfectly content with just that alone
but those after mentioned factions
characters and story were what made this
feel so unique to many players it's
truly what a fallout game should be a
terrifying and welcoming atmosphere
gripping narrative with moral conundrums
and of course great music so today i'm
going to be spending the next however
long this video is explaining why new
vegas is my personal favorite fallout
game of all time from its small quality
of life improvements and wonderful world
building to its contentious ending and
even later to its dlc with the story to
rival its own main quest as always
timestamps are in the description down
below if you want to skip around but if
not let's get started of course with
these types of videos an introduction
and summary is in order as previously
mentioned fallout new vegas is set in
the west coast i'm unsure why bethesda
always makes games in the east and
everything not related to them is in the
west but that's just what we've got
while the general location is the west
coast of the united states its actual
playable area is in nevada right in the
middle of las vegas which means less
city style architecture and more desert
since the previous entry fallout 3 is on
the same game brio engine most of the
gameplay mechanics and ui from fallout 3
remained unchanged but new vegas decided
to tweak some sections of it for example
damage resistance is now changed to
damage threshold damage resistance and
fallout 3 was a percentage whereas the
threshold was a complete subtraction
font in vegas also has the same number
of skills as fallout 3 being 13 but
removed both big and small guns to make
just guns as well as adding survival
some other changes were made within this
like adding throwable weapons that would
go into melee weapon skills and also
changing what counts as a big gun or
explosive like with the fatman and
missile launcher the game also changed
how perks work but also added traits to
choose from fallout 3 had a max level of
30 with a skill every level but new
vegas has a max level of 50 but a perk
every two levels if you do the numbers
that means new vegas got five fewer perk
choices than three and considering the
fact you have to gain more xp every
level it means going more time without
picking perks making the game harder it
also removed those skill boosting perks
from fallout 3 that allowed you to dump
points into skills using perks
increasing them by close to 30 points
and just a level up and those traits i
mentioned earlier were seen as optional
but additional changes to your starting
setup giving you benefits in certain
areas but decreasing effectiveness in
others among other small changes the
game also added crafting crafting both
in regards to weapons and supplies
allows the player to do exactly as it
sounds reloading benches and workbenches
allowed the player to create and break
down ammunition to make different
calibers or in the case of laser weapons
outright convert energy cells to ones
that match your preferred gun it's also
here but you'll discover mods you can
attach to weapons to increase its stats
and different ammo that you can swap to
on the go all of which have their own
benefits like increasing raw damage or
maybe armor penetration campfires and
hot plates gave the player the option of
creating a wide variety of medicines
chems and poisons while also serving its
most obvious purpose cooking raw food
because of these new mechanics newer
items in the forms of casings materials
and different plants were created to fit
this it's quite clear that while on the
surface both three and new vegas may
look and play similar once you unravel
the folds of both games that's not the
case at all a big reason for this was
the newly added hardcore mode a gamemode
that would receive so much praise it was
added into the later entries hardcore
breaks some of the fundamentals of the
game not only was the player supposed to
manage their food water and sleep meters
regularly companions could actually die
if not prepared enough making them more
than just invincible meat shields while
also changing the basics of healing
forcing you to heal over time and not
instantly something that bethesda would
adopt is a basic mechanic in the future
which i've always been fond of the real
question is why bother bringing any of
this up and i did so for a few reasons
it's not only to catch everyone up to
speed on what's been changing from entry
to entry but it also doubles as a
showcasing of both the game's small
changes to its gameplay loop the
gameplay loop for these games is
exploration combat looting repeat but
both of them offer slight changes to
make these three core parts a bit
different i've already explained a good
portion of this in my fallout 3 video so
if you want to see that explanation you
can go there but in the case of new
vegas it changes the game's gameplay
loop by making the early game slightly
harder than its counterpart of course
that's not saying fallout 3 is bad
because it's easy it's quite the
opposite once again you can go watch
that video but new vegas keeps the same
gameplay loop of exploring the map
finding a location engaging in combat
looting those foolish enough to attack
you then moving on to the next location
to do the exact same thing but it's the
choices in between or even during these
parts of the loop that change the game
and allow new vegas to separate itself
from others within the same series just
as those games separate themselves from
everything else for the rest of the
sections in this video i'm going to try
to steer away from using those other
entries of the series as a way to convey
my point whether good or bad as i feel
that really just displays poor writing
but in this section it's almost
necessary fallout 3 as stated before had
those skill boosting perks one of them
was at level 8 which was called size
matters which is what i explained before
giving the player an extra 15 points
into big guns on top of the 15 you can
do from leveling up giving you 30 points
after one level this helps this portion
of the game a lot but you're sacrificing
the opportunity of picking another skill
that may have also benefited you new
vegas took this idea but adapted it by
removing those skill boosting perks and
giving us a perk every two levels making
that time in between your perk choice
and the next one that much longer the
decision to implement the perks this way
whether intentionally or not really
screws with the player in the early game
should the player decide to put more
into lockpick then they'll be able to
access some early game safes and
goodsprings but because those skill
boosting perks aren't available they
can't have them back them up so for the
good springs fight early in the game
they have to stick with fewer people to
fight the powder gangers or travel the
wasteland to get more xp instead but
seeing as you have very little weaponry
and the only enemies near you are geckos
and rad scorpions you may just have to
suck it up and deal with your decision
or just restart your game it's really
not that late into the game you easily
could do that too this same idea and
challenge tends to stay with you for a
good portion of the early and mid game
but tends to disappear after a while
when you hit those later levels as your
character is more evolved than your
early days of guessing pain swatches
with doc mitchell new vegas had the
tough job of looking like fallout 3 and
somewhat playing like fallout 3. so
obsidian decided that instead of only
changing the story related content of
the game they opted to change the
gameplay as well so it never truly feels
the same from game to game while i
personally don't come back to fault new
vegas time and time again for its
gameplay as that title is safe for
fallout 4 it's one of the most integral
parts of the game and you can't really
blame new vegas or 3 either it's just
that 4 has such an expansive list of
weapon crafting and customization on top
of really crisp and clean gameplay that
it's honestly hard to compete against
the gameplay in new vegas isn't terrible
by any means but it's not the main
reason i love new vegas new vegas has
such a wonderful location and story that
i'm engulfed in the world in front of me
and it all starts from the moment you
step outside i've always been one for
first impressions i usually see the
first hour of the game as the most
important as it's the time frame that
most players will experience good spring
serves as the hub for the player but
also a tutorial it has enough going on
in and around it that it can teach and
provide the player with most things that
they'll need i consider the tutorial
area to be anything within the area
before you get that usual prompt of
wanting to change your stats or skills
this conveniently encompasses all of
good springs and a few key areas outside
the town even before that however we get
a few minutes of cinematics that
showcase different factions and
locations as well as a quick summary of
the mojave and how things came to be
when we arrive but more importantly we
get introduced to our character new
vegas was a huge spin on the series as
it was to most players the first time
they didn't start out as a vault dweller
instead they took the role of a courier
someone who was out delivering a package
and is now staring down the barrel of a
gun that person holding the gun is
purposely painted as unique and
noteworthy instead of using typical
tribal or residential clothing that we
see all over the game obsidian purposely
dressed benny in a checkered suit making
him easily remembered and it's here
where he delivers one of the most iconic
lines in the game
from where you're kneeling must seem
like an 18-carat run of bad luck
truth is
the game was rigged from the start
this scene leaves us with more questions
than answers but one thing's for certain
obsidian is definitely taking a
different approach to its storytelling
in fault new vegas being the courier is
the plot if you take this away there's
no fallout new vegas the game constantly
harkens back to not only your job but
this exact contract both in the main
quest and in the dlc as well making the
entire story very reciprocating
constantly giving the player new
storylines and plots but also recalling
that original idea that you're still
just a courier getting back to good
springs after leaving doc mitchell's
house we finally get to see the outside
world we can walk across the coarse sand
all while the sun beats down on us
there's even the occasional mini dust
tornado in the street that kicks up sand
and dirt everywhere it's clear that the
mojave is not only hot but really dry
the player is free to explore and go
anywhere but it's definitely encouraged
you stay within good springs here we can
meet sunny who gives us a tutorial of
the game's mechanics we previously
mentioned but while going through this
tutorial one of our tasks lead us to a
hill near the saloon where we can see a
very large structure in the distance
it's not much of a sight early in the
morning but it's something the player
will definitely notice once finished
with our job we enter the saloon again
and hear an altercation now whether we
talk to joe about this discussion or
trudy we understand that something's
going on in good springs and it's about
to happen soon this is also a tutorial
even if the player isn't being
explicitly told what to do it's giving
the player their first sidequest but
also teaching the player about factions
and how their decisions can impact the
game going forward this quest has two
ways of completing it you could either
join trudy and the other settlers of
goodsprings to fight against the powder
gangers or join the powder gangers and
terrorize the town that just saved your
life this decision doesn't really have a
large impact on the game as a whole as
it's just a tutorial but it's showing
the player that not everything is a
one-way trip sometimes there'll be more
than one choice or in some cases seven
choices but we'll talk about that later
after the skirmish it should be close to
night time and i can't help but feel
that this was deliberate as that same
exact structure from earlier is now
completely changed no matter if you were
someone who watched the promotional
trailer leading up to the game's release
paid attention to the intro cinematic or
skipped all of it one thing goes through
everybody's heads that's the end goal no
matter what direction we go in whether
we're going completely straight to it or
following the roads and progressing
through the story first that's where we
all want to go it's incredible how this
one beacon of light changes everything
about the player behind us is just a
bleak and dark town of settlers just
trying to get by this is something else
entirely a ray of hope shining across
all of the mojave telling the player
that it's gonna be okay it's a very
powerful set piece that can be seen for
pretty much 80 to the map in the north
from nellis air force base and jacob's
town and even in the south with black
mountain obsidian wants you to go here
and you'll go here whether you want to
or not as it's hard to not stare at
probably the tallest structure in the
game and not want to see what's inside
keep in mind this all occurs in one hour
we get a tutorial of the game's
mechanics a brief look at the faction
system letting us know that the choices
we make and have consequences while also
giving the player two goals one being
the main quest and the other being the
player's own personal goal of reaching
the strip even if both goals end up in
the same place the player doesn't know
that yet it's just simply remarkable and
one of the best opening hours of a game
i've played in a long time it manages to
pull on the player from the very moment
and continuously leave this breadcrumb
trail for the player to follow after
this tutorial the player is encouraged
to wander the waste now that they've
understood how to play the game and this
is where that exploration of the game
really shines one thing players will
notice about the mojave is the enemies
bethesda's main formula for fallout has
always been a large number of deathclaws
mirelurks super mutants feral ghouls and
of course the brotherhood of steel but
with new vegas it's the complete
opposite the aforementioned groups
either don't exist in this game or are
only in a couple locations throughout
the map this makes everything feel fresh
and new it changes the dynamic of combat
by introducing new enemies all with
different strengths and weaknesses
against a mirelurk the goal is obviously
to aim for the small slit where their
head is located since their shell has
lots of armor after knowing this in the
first game you don't ever need to
relearn this as the games never change
that formula niken may just look like
super mutants but they're actually
faster and can use stealth voice to hide
in plain sight and herein lies another
part of these enemies some of them are
really tough even at max rank with power
armor a deathclaw will still kill you in
a few hits and while one casador might
not be a problem three or four rushing
you at top speed is a different story it
made me adapt and change how i played
this series since i was being challenged
by newer enemies just as everyone was
shocked to see how tough giants were in
skyrim for the first time everyone
probably had the same feeling with
kazadors on the surface they look like
bigger bloat flies but they hit like
deathclaws and the fact that they were
super fast didn't help it either but
deathclaws themselves are on a whole
nother level i still remember the first
time i cleared a quarry junction and
that was some of the sweatiest i've ever
played it's got the feeling of doing a
raid in your favorite mmo but in one
location i felt like a god walking out
of that place that i just accomplished
the hardest task in the game even if i
were mere inches from death myself new
vegas never stops being tough thanks to
these enemies and i love it i don't have
a problem with living out a power
fantasy in my games being able to one
shot anyone who even dares look in my
direction but i feel better when time
and time again new vegas humbles me by
letting me know i'm not as strong as i
think i am in the way that i played in
the early game planning my attack
carefully so i don't waste the little
ammo i have is translated to these
enemies except at every single point in
the game it's quite obvious that from
the get-go the mojave is a lot different
than the capital wasteland or the
commonwealth and not just in its enemy
variety but also in its design and i may
be in the minority here but i don't
really like the mojave as opposed to the
other two and i think that's the issue
with building a world in a desert it's
so open the best part about fallout 3
and 4 was those cramped cities while not
particularly great to look at this
coupled with gunshots and explosives
going off in the distance made the
player feel a sense of dread and
nervousness that at any moment a group
of raiders or super mutants could ambush
you from an alleyway you don't even know
was there there are lots of locations in
these games with small alleyways or
corridors that lead to someone's base of
operations and it's hard to pull off
something like that when 99 of the map
is desert the majority of the time once
you've seen it once you've seen it all
that's actually a huge reason why i love
76's design as the multiple different
lands all inside the one map are
gorgeous and provide a fresh environment
for the player to look at as they climb
to the levels but that's really the only
negative i have is while the location to
location exploring can be quite a drag
the actual locations and stories within
them are truly bizarre walking from
boulder city to hoover dam while short
is not visually appealing as it's just
rocks and concrete but once you make it
to hoover dam however that completely
changes the mood or even with jacob's
town while much more unique than the
rest of the map it's still this long
walk up a windy mountain before you
reach the beautiful wooded mansion and i
think that's the best way to explain
most of the exploration in this game
there is a famous saying it's about the
journey not the destination but with new
vegas i've always felt that it's the
destination that matters not the journey
and if you're willing to set aside that
boring walk you'll be greeted with some
of the most captivating and outlandish
areas in fallout to date one of those
locations being the game's vaults new
vegas has no shortage of vaults as there
are six scattered throughout the mojave
for those who don't know every vault has
a story and more than likely will be bad
for example vault 3 is located near
outer vegas which was actually one of
the few control vaults in the series
except when a water leak sprung in the
vault the overseer had to open it and
ask for assistance in the outside world
except that outside world was filled
with raiders who killed everyone and
took over the vault or there's vault 22
which is overgrown with large plants as
the plan of the vault was to combat
world hunger by testing various
different fertilizers and crop producers
one of these creations was a spore that
was used as a pest control which was
designed to inhabit the host and kill it
from the inside people in the vault
didn't think this spore would infect
them due to it being used for pests only
and not humans but that was entirely
untrue on top of that the body continues
to operate after death causing the spore
monsters we see in the vault but easily
the best vault and the most bone
chilling as well is vault 11. located
near el dorado dry lake upon entering
vault 11 we see a few insects but more
importantly is a group of skeletons on a
terminal nearby we can hear a hollow
tape of their conversation
are we really gonna do this
it's open we could just leave
i couldn't not after that we don't
deserve to leave
a shining example
that's what it called us
but we were we did what we were supposed
to
not by a long shot
anybody would have done what we did
yes me that's exactly the problem now
let's get on with this
i'll go first
wait wait people should know what
happened they could learn from it
if there's anyone out there at all i
hope they never have to find out
ready harry
yeah
no no no wait
something bad clearly happened here bad
enough for all of them to consider
suicide except one decided to kill
everyone probably in hopes of spreading
the story around the vault we can see
pictures for an election every vault has
a top-ranking official known as an
overseer and it seems like the current
one's term was up at the time of the
arrival but this is where the confusion
starts one of the posters says haley is
a known adulterer and communist
sympathizer elect haley is overseer
usually you want someone in power who's
not a problematic person but it seems to
be the opposite in this vault another
one says don't vote glover his family
needs him we can also read a few
terminal entries that really showcase
the darkness that consume this vault one
member of the vault named kate overheard
that her husband was possibly going to
be endorsed by a group called the block
leadership she confronted the group and
they decided that they wouldn't if she
slept with all of them she agreed but
was betrayed as they endorsed him anyway
this led to her killing the people
within the group she did this on purpose
however as she was now guaranteed the
overseer position because she issued
overseer order 745 which changed the
rules of the election no longer would
the person most voted by the vault be
overseer but rather it was random and it
wasn't yearly anymore but rather monthly
this led to the eventual downfall of the
vault as everyone was fighting amongst
each other and many died because of it
the few survivors that were left were
the five we hear on the hollow tape and
as we know they committed suicide but
the reason behind it is not what you
think upon entering the overseer's
office we can find a tunnel that leads
to some horrific discoveries this vault
was designed around sacrifice this would
make sense why the election was about
the worst candidate as the dwellers
would rather have the worst person in
the vault die rather than the best what
we are walking down is what the other
overseers walked into before they were
sacrificed
greetings murder and welcome
if you're here now it means you've been
offered up as a sacrifice so that your
vault can continue to thrive you've led
a great life
living it has been its own reward
but it is only the beginning close your
eyes now
and imagine what joys await you in the
next life
the afterlife
can you see them good
not only was the person stepping into
this room going to die they didn't even
die in honorable or respectful way as
they were executed via firing squad by a
dozen robots if you managed to live this
ambush you could find dozens of
skeletons all over the ground most
likely belonging to the other overseers
that tried to escape but the story
doesn't end here those five remaining
dwellers decided to not send anyone as a
sacrifice why not if they're gonna die
in here anyway might as well see what
happens if they don't all right i know
you can hear me so listen up
there's five of us left
five out of i don't know how many so
it's over
we've talked and it's over we're not
gonna send anybody to die anymore
so shut off our water or gases or do
whatever it is you're programmed to do
but we're done listening to you
congratulations citizens of vault 11.
you have made the decision not to
sacrifice one of your own you can walk
with your head held high knowing that
your commitment to human life is a
shining example to us all
and to make that feeling of pride even
sweeter
i have some exciting news
despite what you were led to believe
the population of vault 11 is not going
to be exterminated for its disobedience
instead
the mechanism to open the main vault
door has now been enabled and you can
come and go at your leisure
but not so fast
be sure to check with your overseer to
find out if it's safe to leave
here at vault tech your safety is our
number one priority
i can't imagine the amount of guilt and
sadness and just overall confusion that
was going through these people's heads
that if they didn't just sacrifice
anyone at the start everyone would be
alive in terms of the overall story and
shock this vault is easily within the
top three this vault was partially
inspired by the milgram experiment as
well and as someone who's taken quite a
few psychology courses in college i was
very amazed to see how similar they both
are to spare you the hours of research i
had to do to write a paper on this
essentially the experiment would start
with shocking an individual and
eventually the person controlling the
voltage would hear the person they were
shocking has a heart problem they would
hear the screams of the other man on the
outside but would refuse to continue so
that they don't kill him but an
authority figure would step in saying
you have to finish the test that you
have no choice that you have to finish
this because of that even though the
test subjects could have easily walked
out of the building at any time they
stayed and continued to shock him
despite knowing that they could kill
this man the man wasn't actually being
shocked it was all a test to see whether
an authority figure could overpower a
person's morals which after testing
found out a very high percentage of
people obeyed the instructions despite
the risks this whole thing was actually
started to determine whether or not they
should arrest nazi soldiers as it was
argued that while they did kill people
they were just following orders and
should not be at fault because of it
like i said i wrote an entire paper on
this thing but it's obvious to see the
parallel between the two the vault
dwellers at any point in time could have
just stopped killing people but because
some random authority figure claimed
they would die they continued no one
bothered to question the possibility of
their deaths happening but why would you
when your life is on the line i think if
i had to introduce someone to the vaults
of fallouts and how wonderful these
locations are to visit and that that
mystery of what happened in here really
intrigues you the moment you step in i
would show them vault 11. it's the
perfect balance of engagement and plot
twist that allows the writers of this
game to really showcase their creativity
they're not bound by any overarching
story just any story they come up with
in the vault as they're a story all on
their own so it allows for these bizarre
and depressing stories of the conditions
these people had to live in the vaults
have always been my favorite optional
content in a fallout game and new vegas
did not disappoint the vaults only make
up six locations of the mojave so this
is just a very small amount of locations
the player can visit and while some of
these locations are small cabins or
ruins that could maybe take two minutes
to fully scavenge there's tons of places
well worth the time it takes to get to
do you remember a bit ago when i said i
like those city style areas with fallout
3 freeside is the perfect example every
now and then some random junkie or local
will ambush you when you arrive and
there's even an unmarked quest where one
of them lures you into a back alley only
for him and his boys to open fire on you
it perfectly encapsulates what freeside
really is it's a slum but it's also a
place where its inhabitants are
constantly being taunted of the
greatness on the other side of the door
it's like a kingdom where people are
living rich in lavish lifestyles
dressing in elegant clothing and sipping
the finest of wines but outside the
kingdom is a run-down land full of
darkness freeside has always been my
favorite location in the game but the
area closest to the strip's northgate is
easily the better of the two here we
have the atomic wrangler owner of one of
the weirdest quests i've played of all
time next door is the silver rush and
energy weapons dealer and an overall
good questline but across the street is
the most bizarre faction in this game
talking a little less fighting
you've helped us plenty so i'll tell you
what
just this once name whatever you want
and if i can make it happen it's done
everything you're probably thinking is
absolutely correct yes the king looks
and talks like elvis presley this
building pre-war was a school for guys
who wanted to imitate elvis presley the
king doesn't know who he is considering
he was born after the bombs blew up so
he just assumed people saw him as a god
so they wore all the clothes in the
school and now talk and act like him the
kings also bring up a good point on how
freeside feels real not just the cities
filled with people but the quests
involved in freeside really flesh out
the area making it seem more than just a
playable area created in a game not only
does freeside have everything one would
expect in an area like this like the
previously mentioned bar or weapons
dealer but on the other side of freeside
there's a convenience store and there's
also a base of operations for the
followers of the apocalypse these
generous people accept everyone and help
everyone which in a slum like this is
most definitely needed but as i
mentioned before it's the quests here
that really tie everything together for
the van graffs of the silver rush you
can ask if they have any work and their
first job is putting you on guard duty
you're given the rundown of how to talk
to customers or how to judge who to let
in it was eye-opening usually many
quests and rpgs have the protagonist do
incredible or heroic feats saving a
doctor stopping an assassination not
guard duty freeside is covered with
these small and realistic quests after
guard duty you're sent to deliver a
package literally your old job is a
courier in one mission get the package
deliver it return end of the quest for
even more examples the atomic wrangler's
a bar so it's no surprise people make
tabs but some people haven't been paying
those tabs so you extort them for money
for the follows of the apocalypse you
can also check on two addicts in
freeside then confront the dealer to
make them stop and even for the kings
they seem to be very suspicious of a
bodyguard in freeside who is hired to
keep people safe and after running
around with him you realize he's just a
fraud all of these quests are either
tied to some much larger side quest or
their own separate quest but all of them
at most take like five minutes to
complete they flesh out the area so much
that it felt real and that's why it's
always been my favorite area in the game
freeside isn't just some random town or
city that just exists because the
developers made it it seems like it's
its own area away from the player's
control and it's reinforced by these
quests even if one of them is about a
sex bot one thing most of these quests
were missing however was options even
though the player had multiple ways of
going about these quests they all ended
roughly the same i even said at the
beginning of the video that the good
springs fight was a tutorial to teach
the player that not everything is a
one-way trip but i have yet to defend
that statement so let me introduce to
you beyond the beef beyond the beef has
two endings but if you were to add the
alternative routes within them it's more
like seven the quest can start in two
ways from walter phoebus or heck
gundersen walter is at the strip because
he heard heck gundersen was here the
problem is that both of them are farmers
and walter's farm was taken from him at
gunpoint and he suspects that heck was
behind it we can offer to help him take
care of heck and he tells us that he's
located in the ultraluxe casino just
behind him the ultra luxe is owned by
the white glove society one of the three
families of the strip along with the
omertas and the chairman but the white
gloves are different whereas the omertas
focused on prostitution and the chairman
are all about charisma and entertainment
the white glove's about high quality
cuisine if you're a connoisseur of fine
dining and elegant eatery you can come
here it's clear from their office that
they even have a strict dress code no
one looking like us would be allowed to
enter under normal circumstances at the
bar is heck gunderson with an armed
guard upon starting a conversation with
him he talks about a missing person and
that this specific missing person is his
son ted he wants us to be his private
investigator to uncover the mystery for
ourselves with all the cards on the
table we can talk to walter about our
findings and even after letting him know
that his son is missing he still wants
us to go through with killing him we'll
get to walter's side of the story later
but for now let's continue this
investigation the first person we can
talk to is the front desk lady marjorie
we can let her know that we're
investigating the missing person's
report and since we're new on the case
we want to get caught up to speed on all
the info being shared but she seems
rather defensive and lays the huge
bombshell on us that the white glove
society will never consume human flesh
and never has before it's kind of like
digging for copper and finding gold we
asked about the missing person not about
cannibalism but now that you've brought
it to our attention kind of makes me
want to know about the cannibalism part
she also tries to cover this very large
hole she's already dug herself into by
saying before that the white glove
society were known as a different group
and that they did do some stuff in the
past but that's all behind them this is
almost like a politician saying they're
going to reduce taxes in an area then
reduce it by such a minimal amount that
it doesn't even make a difference taken
literally they did their job but can you
really even accept that as a response
from them the next person we question is
a man named mortimer just like marjorie
we can ask him about the missing person
and also like marjorie he gives us way
more info than we asked for he talks
about the previous investigator and that
he was trying to find the missing bride
so that means there were two people who
have gone missing here it's the
apocalypse it's not out of the ordinary
for people to be kidnapped but two
people in such a short amount of time at
the same place and here of all places
it's a little fishy if you told me the
omertos were kidnapping people you
wouldn't even need to give me evidence
and i would have believed you right away
the ultra lux that's different but now
with this information it seems like
something really is going on here
playing along with him we can ask for
more info on the case and he'll give us
some guest information as we enter the
room we see the investigator dead on the
floor and immediately are attacked by
some white glove members thankfully i
had my pistol on me or that could've
been quite messy if nothing was
evidenced before this is easily all we
need to come up with the conclusion that
the white gloves are hiding something it
seems the investigator was going to meet
with someone in the steam room possibly
an informant and when we arrive we see
chauncey a white glove society member
who explains that mortimer and some of
the other members want to go back to
their animalistic ways and not only dine
on human flesh but serve it at the
ultralux mortimer plans to cook ted and
after having the other members dine on
the food he'll reveal that it was human
flesh and now that their accomplices in
his crime of eating and killing a person
they'll either accept it willingly or be
forced to afterward chauncey is killed
but not before giving us enough
information on how to complete this
quest in a couple ways we can drug the
wine that they serve at the dinner and
have everyone pass out or change the
recipe and have mortimer think everyone
is eating flesh then once he reveals his
master plan we walk out with ted and
embarrass him in front of the others to
do this we need to get to the basement
first and there's numerous ways to
approach this from being sponsored by
marjorie or just sneaking inside if we
go in order first we can drag the wine
which causes everyone to pass out with
everyone passed out we can sneak ted out
of the basement and back to heck
completing the quest alternatively we
can change the recipe and foil
mortimer's plan causing him to flee
while everyone stands around once again
we can take him to heck and finish the
quest if puzzle solving is boring you
can also just shoot the place up and
save ted that way even better once you
discover what happened to the
investigator you can talk to heck about
your findings and he'll offer to shoot
it up with you so already we have four
ways of finishing this quest but when
talking to heck we can influence the
strip even more when talking to him
about finding ted he'll ask us who the
culprits were and from here we have
three options we can simply lie and say
we don't know who did it blame only
mortimer and some of the members of the
white gloves or throw the entire group
under the bus by outing the entire group
heck opts to just let the strip starve
and refuse to sell any meat to anybody
on the entire strip the other options is
that heck lives with the fact that while
he got his son back he'll never know who
kidnapped him or be satisfied that he
found the people responsible and doesn't
hold it against the group all that much
since not everyone was involved so it's
four options where two of them lead to
three additional options that shaped the
future of the strip but ultimately led
to heck and ted being reunited but
that's not all when talking to mortimer
if you have a high enough speech skill
or the cannibal perk you can let him
know that you also like to dine on flesh
this convinces him enough to spill all
the information on the entire operation
and from here once again we have
numerous ways of tackling this after
discussing with mortimer about the plan
he reveals ted wasn't actually supposed
to be captured they wanted some other
person who was going to be this heir to
a mercantile empire and that because he
cut ties with his family no one was
going to know he was gone but they
failed to capture him and now he's on
the run and knows his captors faces
mortem asked for a last-minute
alternative and they thought the son of
the head brahman baron in the mojave was
a great idea thus leading to the issue
at hand our first option is helping
resolve the issue by capturing the
original person since he doesn't know
who we are he won't expect another
kidnapping he lives out in a shack north
of new vegas and to do this properly we
can knock him out with a cattle prod or
pistol weapon but we can't have two main
courses so we have to resolve things
with ted so we knock out sinclair and
talk to ted alternatively instead of
sinclair we can also offer up our own
companion surprisingly mortimer is fine
with this alternative as all we have to
do is just block him in the same freezer
as head being then convinced ted this
was all a misunderstanding and if we do
convince him that he got mixed up in
some stuff he wasn't supposed to be a
part of we can take him to heck and then
go back to those three options again
just like the other side of the quest
though there is a faster less puzzling
way of ending things and just shooting
ted in the freezer and framing his
father we can kill ted in the freezer
then plant his blood in heck sweet here
at the ultralux we can then talk to a
securatron and report his crime who will
then proceed to shoot heck completing
our quest but remember walter wanted
heck dead so we can use this opportunity
to complete his quest as well we return
to walter who will be happy the deed is
done and says that he's going to go back
to his ranch and continue farming so
let's go over this again starting with
the good ending we have four options of
saving ted by killing everyone in the
casino alone killing everyone in the
casino with heck saving ted by poisoning
the wine or saving him by replacing the
recipe with the regular meat foiling
mortimer's plans this then leads to the
three ending options of exposing the
whole society exposing some of its
members or not exposing anyone on the
other side we can complete the evil
ending if you choose a companion or
sinclair this leads to the same three
options as the last ending but if you
kill ted and frame his father heck will
die and not only complete the beyond the
beef quest but also the quest with
walter this is a whopping seven options
for finishing this quest and that's not
even counting the three options at the
end that changed the strip's future
which makes that number even larger this
quest allows for an insane amount of
role playing and decision making this
next part is going to be a bit of theory
crafting and not something that actually
occurs in game but humor me for a bit
let's say we go the evil route and
convert the white gloves back into
cannibals this means philippe the head
chef needs to continue his recipe of
human flesh according to his notes is
essentially veal but it tastes like
human flesh i'm not a connoisseur of
human meat but i'm assuming to mask the
smell and possible taste from being too
strong so that the visitors know that
they're not eating real meat need to
sprinkle in some actual meat into the
recipe also it might be too hard for the
ultralux to keep up the demand for human
meat if the recipe sells well so they
may also have to get regular meat on the
menu s to not stand out too much this
means regardless they're going to need
both flesh and animal meat so depending
on our ending we can swap ted for
sinclair which checks off the human
flesh then when explaining to heck what
happened we framed no one thus it's
possible he would still continue to deal
business with the white gloves checking
off our animal needs but heck could be
seen as a loose end and it's possible
that he still may even suspect the group
even when we come up with no evidence
who captured his son so he won't be
selling brahmin meat to the society but
still the strip but if we instead frame
him walter might be the next possible
candidate and i think that's the best
possible option to get the perfect evil
ending in my mind we help the white
glove society become cannibals we also
frame heck and since him and his son are
dead there's no loose ends left for the
society to tie up and now since heck is
out of the picture the best possible
brahmin farmer in the mojave could be
walter now he can do business with the
ultralucks and doesn't even have an
ounce of suspicion as to what's going on
since he has no ties to them keeps
everything business as usual with the
white gloves going back to their
animalistic ways the fact that i not
only had to show a flow chart to explain
the endings but took the time to
consider the possible ramifications of
all the options and came up with a best
possible ending for one side really
shows how good this quest line is it's
equal parts comprehensive and engaging
it's by far my top three and i'd argue
my favorite in all of fallouts i'd
probably have to think about that last
part a bit but it's easily within the
top three it's a blueprint for what i
quest in fallout can be and maybe not
have this many options but even if it
had half the options beyond the beef
head it could be an incredible quest
that no one would forget in an effort to
wrap up this whole section on
exploration fault new vegas really
shines in this department as i said
while it's atmosphere and may not be the
most pleasing to the eye once you reach
those many locations within the game
you'll be rewarded for doing so with
interesting quests and locations that
are iconic and timeless even though most
of those quests and locations weren't
featured in this video and i wanted to
take a different approach to the writing
of new vegas than i did with fallout 3.
instead of writing multiple locations in
quests with short summaries i wanted to
instead cover a smaller amount of them
but go more in depth regardless if you
remember what i said earlier in the
video i said that combat while okay in
new vegas was not the reason i come back
to this game and throughout the video
i've shown you small reasons i come back
like the mind bending vaults and the
beautiful fleshed-out towns but two
biggest reasons and the two reasons why
fallout has still remained my favorite
game is the story in dlc the story of
fault new vegas has always been my
favorite in the franchise and will
probably stay my favorite for a long
time while the other games in the series
have good stories nothing compares to
how well written this narrative is when
the community of a 10 year old game
still discusses what ending is better
for the setting's future that really
says something it's been debated for
years and everyone gives really good
points to support their stance and
that's the issue there are very few
cracks that can be exploited to shut
down a person's claim mostly because we
don't know the actual futures of the
ending minus a few slides at the end but
mostly because this game was never about
being black and white it's always
remained in the gray and it all starts
at the beginning the first part of the
main quest is trying to find benny so we
can get the platinum chip back which is
the item we were delivering before many
intercepted us through following the
main quest the player will encounter two
of the most important factions in the
game as i've stated before first
impressions are important and these
upcoming areas are going to be the
player's first time interacting with
these factions after exiting springs and
going south we'll enter prim and walking
down the street we see a flag labeled
the new california republic which a
soldier of this group stops and warns us
of the danger ahead it's clear without
learning much about them that they seem
to be a more militarized faction not
just in the way they dress but how they
communicate with the player they talk
like how soldiers would communicate
orders and information to each other not
some random local looking to rob caps
off you at this point it's the only
interaction we have with this ncr
faction we don't learn much about them
but considering they're more military
than raider we kind of get the gist
already but if the player were to take a
quick detour even further south as
opposed to going east into nipton then
their idea of them being a military
group is further reinforced as they have
outposts guards command centers mess
halls and top ranking officers amongst
the common soldier all sporting the ncr
insignia they seem like the typical good
guy faction just trying to help out the
mojave same cannot be said for the other
faction we meet as upon entering nipton
we see a powder ganger running up to us
screaming about winning the lottery
considering we're in the apocalypse it's
quite surprising that lotteries are even
still happening i also can't imagine the
payout would be all that large either
nearby him is a small store we can visit
and it's probably a good idea to go
inside first so we can stock up on some
food and possibly medicine just in case
things go wrong
are you [ __ ] kidding me
first i get my legs smashed and then in
walks the powder ganger's grim [ __ ]
reaper what the [ __ ] have you got
against us man jesus [ __ ] christ if
you want me dead just give me 15 medics
and i'll [ __ ] od for you okay
[ __ ]
huh apparently boxcars was the runner up
in the lottery so while he lived they
smashed his legs in and now he can't
walk boxcars further explains the
ranking of this lottery the first people
to get drawn got decapitated everyone
else got crucified third place
runner-ups got enslaved and we already
know what happened to first and second
place the group who did this claimed
that people needed to be punished so
they hosted a lottery to see who
deserved it and once we exit the store
we can find that group we walk down the
main street and see everything boxcar
described there's fire and crosses
everywhere and here's where we meet the
legion instead of a regular soldier like
with the ncr we see a named npc called
the volpes in colta boxstar's story was
backed up by vault base explaining how
they captured everyone and how the
lottery worked it's also here where we
can tell the difference at affinities to
caesar their leader this is the same way
that skyrim showed who aligned with who
during the war just like people saying
by the 8 or by the 9 in skyrim
referencing talos anyone who hates
caesar will say caesar while anyone who
likes him within the legion will say
kaisar this is a helpful way to
determine the allegiance of many people
in the game and extremely important in
the dlc the legion's entrance was the
complete opposite of the ncrs instead of
being more formal and helpful the legion
is shown to be ruthless and insane and
while that may seem like the end of the
factions throughout our time exploring
these locations we've actually been
introduced to the third faction who is
mr house victor is a sakuratron that we
meet at goodsprings and is actually the
one who saved us we can express our
gratitude to him and ask how he found us
he says that he was just simply taking a
midnight stroll and stumbled upon us
sentient robots aren't out of the
ordinary in this game and most could
just brush this off as luck too but the
issue is we see victor again and not
just once but three more times once
after leaving good springs once at novak
and the last time at the lucky 38 it
seems like he's leading us somewhere and
he most definitely is as when we enter
the lucky 38 and take the elevator we
meet mr house the sole proprietor of new
vegas mr house was actually the one who
commissioned the delivery of the
platinum chip we discovered a little
earlier in prim when visiting the mojave
express that we were one of seven
couriers delivering items for this
contract this is so that no one courier
could be singled out and found house
hired seven couriers to carry certain
items with six of them being fakes we
just happen to be the one carrying the
actual chip house tells us that the chip
is actually filled with data this data
can then upgrade the securitrons of the
strip to give them enhanced weaponry mr
house had originally commissioned this a
day before the bombs dropped so we can
kind of see how after 200 years he still
doesn't have it but now that we have the
chip back mr house tries to convince us
to help him and not just in upgrading
the robots but taking over the hoover
dam and this is where we start to learn
about the actual end game plot since
this game is in las vegas the hoover dam
is part of the map and currently the ncr
holds it but just across the other side
is caesar's legion who wants to take the
damn from the ncr house wants to take it
from both of them and use that power for
new vegas but we aren't even finished
here upon killing benny we can go into
his back room in one of the suites and
find a securatron named yes man yes man
was an ai used by benny to take control
of new vegas right from under mr house's
nose so we have two routes the mr house
ending of controlling vegas with him or
taking control of vegas ourselves we can
then go outside and mull over the
information until both an ncr trooper
and volpace again gives us directions to
meet their superiors we now have
officially hit the game's intersection
so let me clarify this a bit from the
information we can gather we assume the
ncr wants to recruit us to protect the
dam and defeat the legion caesar the
leader of the legion wants to recruit us
to overtake the dam and then probably
the mojave with the legion mr house
wants to defeat both the ncr and the
legion to secure an independent new
vegas owned by mr house and yes man
wants to defeat the ncr and the legion
and mr house to once again get a free
and independent new vegas but ruled by
us the player it can be quite a lot to
take in at this moment as everything is
kind of happening all at once but this
establishes lots of options to the
player at this point the player is given
four different paths to take and while
you can flip-flop between them at some
point you'll have to choose a side
eventually giving us time to figure out
what we want to do and also give us a
chance to talk to the leaders will give
us a good idea of who we're fighting
with and why the only endings where this
really isn't apparent is the ncr and yes
man though the ncr is helped by the fact
that they own 90 of the map and thus can
be seen everywhere making it easy to
really get a sense of the faction
structure and for yes man it doesn't
really matter because you're the boss
it's your ending it's not necessary to
understand his point of view since he's
just your yes man he follows your orders
these discussions and how they talk to
us during this quest really puts into
perspective who they are and it's
genuinely my favorite part about these
endings a simple google search will
showcase videos for all the factions
even the legion all explaining why they
think the faction that they're talking
about will help the mojave prosper
within these videos is not only praise
for that faction but criticism for
others some even have asked the question
what would happen if the courier wasn't
even involved at all it's so interesting
to hear everyone's viewpoints and
responses it gets the community excited
to discuss a topic they're passionate
about but also allows people to show off
their knowledge no other ending maybe
besides fallout 4 is talked about this
much with such quality the player is
given four options but not a single one
is the obvious good choice according to
steam most players finish the ncr ending
over the others and it's easy to see why
there's really not much wrong with this
faction they're a fairly inclusive group
including women in ghouls which might be
seen as the bare minimum to some but
it's already a step above caesar and
given the circumstances they seem to be
doing pretty okay with them in charge
but numerous soldiers question the
current leadership even caesar and mr
house agree that the ncr is spreading
its numbers too thin while they have the
capability to take land over from others
it doesn't really matter if they can't
hold it chief hanlon a veteran of the
ncr serving for close to 40 years claims
that holding the dam may be the fall of
the ncr there's even a whole side quest
where you find out he's been falsifying
reports back to command and when
confronted on the issue he explains that
he believed the ncr was fighting a
losing battle so he falsified all his
reports to get more soldiers medicine
and ammo sent to them since he didn't
want these rangers here at the fort to
die for a piece of land that he wasn't
even sure that they would hold long
after they won assuming they even won to
begin with mr house also expresses his
idea of the ncr with one very iconic
line nothing to impede progress
if you want to see the fate of
democracies look out the windows
and out that window was a wasteland
which says if a democracy got us into
this mess how is it going to get us out
there needs to be a change one example
could not just be a simple tweak in
management or structure but a complete
overhaul which created the legion caesar
is looked upon differently in the eyes
of the community the ncr on the surface
is good guys but have a lot of
corruption going on on the inside the
legion is viewed the opposite they are
from the moment we lay eyes on them
ruthless enslaving tribes using women as
breeders and tons of other insane ideas
but it's not like everything is bad
while the aforementioned statement
definitely makes the legion seem awful
caesar is just using the strengths of
each gender effectively i think caesar
understands that women are more than
capable of fighting in the legion but
since they're the only ones who can bear
kids they're better suited elsewhere and
not on the front lines is it morally
wrong absolutely but you can't deny the
fact that because he's using people at
their utmost potential he's able to
prosper because of this speaking of
things prospering trade has been
wonderful for some of the people in the
mojave we could talk to dale barton at
the legion fort who's an independent
merchant he says that the legion is some
of his best customers there's no tax in
legion territory unlike the ncr and
since the legion is ruthless all the
trade routes are safe to travel in it's
allowed dale to make lots of money from
them so even under the rule of the
legion the single most disturbing and
ruthless faction in the game there are
still positives enough to make a decent
argument for them mr house and yes man
are seen as third party options but both
of these are just like the previous two
except just a little harder to make
arguments for mr house is a destructive
army of securitrons under his wing and
can use them to uphold law and order but
his goals are selfish mr house wants to
take over the dam by defeating the
legion and making the ncr surrender with
one main goal in sight the evolution and
advancement of the human race mr house
is unique in the sense that he's
thinking long term he doesn't care about
the villages in the mojave or creating a
government he has an endgame goal in
sight that spans a hundred years in the
future but this is one of his many ways
of persuading the player we as the
player should feel thankful that he
saved us back in good springs but let's
be honest if we didn't have the chip in
our hand he wouldn't give a [ __ ] what
about the other six couriers that
weren't holding the chips did they die
what happened to them
exactly mr house won't even bother
bringing it up because it doesn't matter
he only cares about us because we had
the chip he also persuades us with his
own goals
with all that money pouring in
give me 20 years and i'll reignite the
high technology development sectors
50 years and i'll have people in orbit
100 years and my colony ships will be
heading for the stars to search for
planets
unpolluted by the wrath and folly of a
bygone generation though sound like very
ambitious goals almost too ambitious he
makes lots of claims that are basically
unheard of yet in the series sending
people to orbit minus the bright quest
line i'm sure has never even been done
yet in the fallout series but as many
have said and something i agree with if
anyone's going to make such a bizarre
claim and back it up it's probably going
to be mr house but the question is where
is he getting these funds well as we
discover from the ending it's taxes mr
house earns a sizable amount of income
from the casinos but taxes will easily
boost his profits mr ross plans to run
new vegas solely by himself and when
questioned why that sounds like a
dictatorship he says he prefers the word
autocrat ruling as a chief executive
where he answers to nobody but himself
and if he owns hoover dam he can control
the water and the power from it without
anyone opposing him which is exactly
what he does he makes the water 5 caps
per gallon and electricity 5 caps per
kilowatt hour forgive me for this next
part as it's purely speculation but
since we don't know the conversion rate
for caps to real us dollars it's hard to
get a grasp on this but a gallon of
water in the united states is around a
dollar so in this case a dollar is equal
to five caps which means it's a dollar
per kilowatt hour but even in 2021
according to some studies americans pay
12 cents per kilowatt hour like i said
this is all speculation and has numerous
plot holes but i think it's fair to
assume that even with all the money the
casinos bring in he's gonna need to tax
people to accomplish his goals while mr
house is definitely a decent option as
he's thinking more long term than any
other faction is are his methods of
acquiring these goals really worth it
and does he even care about the people
he's getting the money from mr house has
an army of securitrons defending him
without question and is practically
immortal as long as you don't open his
casing in a hundred years when we can
finally take off to a different planet
as he assumes the people living in the
mojave minus the ghouls won't even be
alive so who cares what they think of
him since he's gonna outlive him anyway
this then brings us to yes man who's
essentially our final choice and the
last straw for the player this is for
the people that think all the options
suck mr house is gonna tax people to
death the legion are gonna enslave
everyone and the ncr might be okay but
they'll probably lose the damn anyway
you're basically taking benny's plan as
your own and you can shape the mojave to
your liking it's the most in-depth
ending out of all of them since you're
the boss you can make the rules and thus
aren't held down by the ideals of anyone
else mr house during his questline wants
the brotherhood destroyed and will
accept nothing less but what if we like
them well we can save them from
annihilation and become allies this in
theory should have no flaws since it's
exactly how the player envisioned the
mojave but the issue is mostly due to
its speculation the endgame slides paint
a good picture of what will happen but
we don't truly know the future only the
near future of the mojave most likely in
the courier's lifetime like in caesar's
ending it says that they overpower new
vegas and enslave everyone but who knows
maybe years later people revolt and kill
the legion or maybe they find out that
slavery was actually a good thing and
new vegas prospers even more under their
rule we don't really know the future our
choices are gonna bring this has caused
many to throw out this ending as a
possible contender since it's so vague
but i just think that's plain wrong it's
an ending but it's our ending which is
why it's so vague every single person
playing this game has differing opinions
just like the factions all have
differing opinions so it's not some
straightforward story with a ton of
questions being answered because it's
not supposed to be and it's impossible
to know everything that will happen to
the insane amount of choices and options
we have say we save the brotherhood of
steel but also cause goodsprings to
prosper who's to say that the
brotherhood don't overtake goodsprings
and use it as a foundation for a new
base we don't know when we never will it
all depends on how you look at things if
you only care about the mojave into your
character's death that's great but some
people tend to think larger past their
own death that's what makes this ending
so hard to talk about it's the very
nature of how this ending is structured
that makes it both incredible and
terrible at the same time but one
thing's for certain all of these
combined make for such an enjoyable
story even today i'm learning new things
about these leaders and taking in other
opinions into account which ultimately
changes my viewpoint on all the leaders
like i said this game is almost 11 years
old and people are still arguing over
whether or not the courier should have
gotten involved in the battle in the
first place and if he didn't what would
have happened to the mojave but if he
did what is the best choice for the
mojave but honestly it's not just the
debates about the best outcome that
hooky win it's the actual story that
does obsidian wants you to care about
the choices you make so they make even
the smallest things matter whether it's
shown to us or not the best example is
in the faction missions while the
mission arcs for each ending differs
slightly a few quests remain consistent
across all of them and those are the
faction missions each leader will ask
you to go to a specific faction and
either potentially foster an alliance or
destroy them this forces the player to
not only explore and uncover more of
those incredible locations we talked
about but also get to understand the
other factions this game has i know i
promised not to bring up the other
entries but in fallout 3's case the game
showed the brotherhood of steel as the
good guys and the enclave is the bad
guys even if your viewpoint was
different it didn't matter since the
game gave you no choices this changed in
broken steel so props to them but
originally it wasn't i bring this up
because as while fallout 3 let you in on
those ideals and beliefs of the factions
or tribes originally you couldn't do
anything with that information but with
new vegas you have the possibility of
changing the entire faction's existence
based on how they treat you if you were
never a fan of the brotherhood of steel
congratulations not only are they a
minor faction in this game you can
literally wipe them off the mojave and
this doesn't just apply to those named
factions either even the smaller towns
like novak a place you might visit for
maybe 20 minutes at most and this brings
me to my other point of player choice
the end game slides fault new vegas has
without a doubt the most slides in the
end game credits for a fallout game at
29. some of these you may not even
achieve so you might not get all 29 but
there's 29 possible options to be shown
to you going back to novak for that
place you spend 20 minutes it has six
possible endings which all depend on the
faction you side with at the end of the
game and if you did the one quest
involved with no back called come fly
with me this one town has six endings
and even better one of my favorite
slides to convey this point is the
misfits when entering camp golf you may
find a group of ncr soldiers these guys
are the misfits terrible soldiers who
were stationed here since no one's going
to accept them they're lazy and
undisciplined and while you can talk to
them you have to speak to the sergeant
of the camp to actually start the quest
then you speak to all four of them
listen to what they think would improve
the squad's behavior then go with
whatever option you choose five minutes
to complete and has an end slide with
five different options if i asked you
would this group of four morons be
mentioned again after this quest is
completed you would probably say no and
that's what i thought when i first did
this mission but was surprised to see
them get their own slide at the end of
the game even the littlest of choices
count in new vegas and while some of
them have greater impact on the game
than others they purposely make those
small decisions matter by giving them
that end credit screen time so you're
constantly thinking about your own
choices for everything in the game in
most games that random person we do a
quest for for maybe two minutes will
never be mentioned again but obsidian
does not want you to think like this
they want you to really care about every
decision you make as it may have
consequences this will ultimately hook
the player and immerse them into the
world and makes everything feel more
fleshed out and real because of it
speaking of our decision or rather the
courier's decision in this case let's
discuss the dlc simply put i love this
game's dlc it does something not many
games do make its own story for example
skyrim story dlcs are dragonborn and
dawnguard each of them can be beaten at
any time and have no relation to the
overall story or the other dlc story
minus the fact that mirak does have ties
to you but still human being for a bit
fall new vegas doesn't do it this way
besides the fact that they made four dlc
with unique and separate stories not
related to each other they also dropped
hints and clues that would eventually
culminate into its own storyline some
claim there's a specific order to
playing these but i always felt that as
long as the lonesome road is last then
any order is fine but i've always played
them in the order of honest hearts old
world blues dead money then lonesome
road and that's how we'll be discussing
them now the first three all have a
separate story for the player to
experience but within them are clues and
hints that will eventually lead to the
last dlc they'll have the player stumble
into danger and get wound up into
something they'd never asked to be a
part of for honest hearts you can join
up with a caravan that gets ambushed and
now you're stuck in zion canyon with no
idea how to get back for old world blues
you're teleported to a place called big
mountain where the scientists there rip
out your brain in a dead money you're
captured by father elijah who will kill
you unless you work with him to open the
sierra madre casino all of these connect
to the lonesome road and the story of
the courier not much is known about the
courier we don't have much to go off of
other than the fact that that was our
job being a courier but obsidian decided
to build the storyline around this
question who really is the courier but
once again it wasn't until lonesome road
that any of this started making sense
honest hearts explores the ongoing
conflict between two tribes in a
completely foreign area it's different
from the mojave and thus is new to the
player we meet the tribe leaders joshua
graham and daniel both of whom are from
new canaan or as they call themselves
the new canaanites the new canaanites
were ambushed by the white legs and
driven into the zion canyon where they
meet the other tribes that we see them
leading in game this dlc is about us
resolving the conflict between the white
legs and the other two tribes old world
blues can be summed up in one word
bizarre it's the story of six scientists
who were constantly experimenting and
testing on literally anything they were
some of the smartest minds in the world
they eventually turned themselves into
robots so they could live indefinitely
and continue researching but their
research has started getting more
sinister for the entirety of the dlc we
work with the think tank to defeat
mobius until we realize that mobius
isn't the bad guy dr mobius informs us
other processing units when all the
doctors mobius included were made into
robots due to some recursion loop in
their programming they forgot a lot of
their personality and even their own
name it's this part of their programming
that has caused them to become
desensitized to the experiments they're
doing mobius then removed everything
related to him in the outside world from
the think tank so that any of the robots
in the think tank think that just big
mountain is all there is left in the
world to stop them from exploring
outside and experimenting on the mojave
dead money starts and we're kidnapped at
a brotherhood of steel bunker we're then
defeated with an explosive collar and
are told to open the sierra madre casino
or else we die the person in charge is
father elijah a former elder of the
brotherhood of steel dead money also
shows lots of key plot points like the
cloud mist that consumes the villa and
other technologies like the vending
machines holograms and the hazmat suits
the dlc also forces us to make friends
with three people being dean christine
and dog all because the explosive
collars are linked so if they die we die
and vice versa all of these three dlc
delve into a theme or topics that is
ultimately thought-provoking given the
context of the individual dlc honest
hearts explores the differences in
pacifism and aggression and how
unresolved trauma can have a lasting
impact on an individual it even dips
into some talk about religion culture
and tradition as the tribes take their
culture very seriously and the new
canaanites were actually mormon old
world blues is about a person's morals
and whether the think tanks should be
held accountable for their actions or if
dr mobius was in the right to manipulate
the think tank into believing that
there's nothing outside of big mountain
and dead money is all about greed and
letting go and not just about the money
in the casino but the casino itself as
father elijah has been obsessed with the
casino for years and he isn't willing to
let go of his dream of opening it they
all have wonderful themes and while i
prefer some of the dlc over others they
at least do an excellent job at
something whether that be the story its
characters or its setting this then
leads us to lonesome road and the reason
i gave an extreme summary of the other
three is because we're gonna be going
back to these places soon because of
this dlc lonesome road as we'll find out
is actually two stories one of the
couriers and one of ulysses when we go
near some wreckage we see the message
courier six upon coming out the other
side we see a completely destroyed town
with dust and smoke everywhere it's not
until after we exit the main building
that a voice appears
there's your signal
faint but there
just like ncr
voice without fire without strength
sick
this is ulysses the most confusing yet
most interesting person in the entire
dlc story by listening to his dialect we
notice he's a fan of caesar as he
pronounces his name kaisar ulysses also
leads us on for the entirety of the dlc
if you hate people that never explain
anything and rather speak in roundabout
ways like answering a question with a
question you will genuinely hate this
man
courier six
was career six
like you
and
not
like you
in all the ways that matter
in regards to that last statement he's
not actually wrong on top of learning
about the contract of the mojave express
in prim we also learned that some other
courier was originally going to be the
sixth one for the job but they ended up
backing out of it that was ulysses the
entire dlc revolves around us running
through the divide until we finally meet
ulysses at the end he wants us to take
our lonesome road as he calls it one
that we've taken before and he keeps
bringing that part up about being here
before and that's the main plot of this
dlc ulysses is not a fan of caesar but
he was a frumentari the same rank as
volpes he was originally a part of a
tribe and like many before him were
conquered by caesar to become the legion
as he wandered the waste as a member of
the legion he came across this community
of people elise thought of this place as
a second chance and a way of living
outside the legion but it was annexed by
the ncr so the legion sent a small group
to overtake the city and enslave
everyone ulysses wanted to save the
people of this small community but while
devising a plan the courier was sent by
the ncr to deliver a package unbeknownst
to the courier the package contained
launch codes for the icbm missiles in
the town what happened afterwards is
what we see in the game ulysses blames
us for killing his second chance at life
setting ablaze a community he finally
felt connected to all because we
delivered the device that triggered the
bombs that is ulysses story or at least
the beginning of his story after this
event around 2277 four years before new
vegas he joined up with caesar again who
ordered him to rally a tribe the white
legs this is what i meant in the
beginning about how everything is
connected whether the connection is big
or small ulysses did the same thing we
did to him we accidentally blew up his
second chance at life and he
accidentally got us caught in every
predicament in the dlc's ulysses story
continues in the same way as i ordered
the dlcs in this video which is why i
played in this sequence he rallied the
white legs tribe and attacked the new
canaanites this drove them into zion
canyon and why the white legs are in the
canyon when we arrive with the caravan
ulysses also influenced the creation of
the other dlcs after he drove out the
new canaanites ulysses continued his
journey and eventually found big
mountain when he arrived besides talking
to the think tank he also met two key
people we've already discussed christine
and elijah christine is a knight of the
brotherhood of steel's subgroup the
circle of steel we can then read up on
elijah during the brotherhood questline
back in the mojave and discovered that
he became obsessed with finding
technology that could defeat the ncr so
much so that he sat at helios 1 even
though any attack would mean their
defeat and we know the aftermath of that
since the ncr hold helios 1. elijah
escaped during this battle and was never
seen again pristine was the soldier
tasked with eliminating him elijah
stumbled upon big mountain like ulysses
did and christine followed him before
the two could confront each other she
was captured at the yangzi camp in big
mountain and was experimented on the
scars on her body are what the result
was ulysses ended up saving her by
blowing up half the facility and
eventually after a few days ran into
father elijah who told him about the
sierra madre with the intention being
that elijah would soon die after
entering the villa ulysses clearly
underestimated him going back to the
think tank when ulysses spoke to them he
asked about their history and even with
the recursion loop in their processing
they remembered all their old lives of
america and places outside big mountain
this is how both dlcs started because of
ulysses reminding the think tank of the
old world outside of big mountain that's
what caused that device we touched that
they send out to capture us and thanks
to ulysses elijah found the sierra madre
and while he lived the expedition to the
casino he couldn't open it so he needed
test subjects to open it for him so he
captured people one of them being us do
you see what i mean the courier's
actions of delivering the package
accidentally caused problems for ulysses
and ulysses actions accidentally caused
problems for the courier in light of all
the knowledge he attained from big
mountain he returned to the divide and
attempted to do what the courier did he
wants to reshape the wasteland the way
the courier reshaped the divide as he
realized how powerful a person can be
never in my life before new vegas did i
play a game that connected its dlc this
well it was absolutely genius until you
think a little harder then it gets a
little confusing ulysses gets a lot of
hate from the community mostly because
of his speech patterns but some have
claimed that it's because he was
originally a cut follower for the base
game and they didn't put enough effort
into his character because of this while
the former is true about him being cut
from the game i haven't found any
evidence to support the latter doesn't
mean it's untrue just means i couldn't
find anything but do let me know if you
do find a source the biggest reason that
some may hate him is that he's just
simply a hypocrite he's mad at us
because we nuked the divide except we
didn't we delivered the codes that
activated the nuke we weren't the ones
who pushed the button or devised the
plan we are what couriers are supposed
to be middlemen but we can say the same
for ulysses he rallied the white legs he
talked to the think tank he pointed
elijah to the sierra madre and if you
want to go one step further because he
denied the contract for the platinum
chip we almost died at the hands of
benny but here's the difference between
us and him we don't blame it on him we
blame the respective parties not ulysses
he was just simply a middleman and has
no idea his actions would have this many
consequences just like the courier's
actions also slight tangent isn't it
like an unwritten rule of like mailmen
and couriers to like not look at
people's packages ulysses was a courier
so he should know this but he still
continues to blame us ulysses is a man
who is confused unsure what to do now
that his chance that a new life is gone
instead of thinking rationally he
devises a plan not one that kills the
courier but rather mimics him we're the
courier that's been the point of this
game we're the protagonist and while the
courier explains that he settled in new
reno in california before our time with
him has been in the mojave the mojave to
us was like the divide to ulysses so
he's going to do to our home what we did
to his blow it up that's why he never
attacks us first he wants us to live
with the disaster he causes like how he
had to live with the disaster we caused
ulysses is turning into us we're pretty
much one and the same at this point
except ulysses isn't thinking properly
or rationally at all he can be seen as
the definition of insanity doing the
same thing over and over again expecting
things to change but i don't even think
ulysses wants change more revenge
revenge against the ncr and the legion
for representing new world ideals as he
despises this way of thinking and
revenge against us for taking his second
home from him fault new vegas dlc was
wonderfully crafted it seems like three
dlcs with really cool themes and
settings that added a new story and
adventure for the player to experience
giving them another reason to play new
vegas again but from the moment we step
into the sierra madre zion canyon or
even big mountain we're expecting a very
intriguing linear story that would maybe
be finished in a few hours but that
turned into one gigantic story that's
been being built in the background the
entire game a story that takes the
characters events and themes of each and
connects all of them together in a
cohesive timeline one that i haven't
seen done this well in gaming ever and
at the center of it all was the lonesome
road
fall new vegas is now what will most
likely be for the foreseeable future my
favorite game in the franchise
originally in the intro i said this
exact same line but with no reasons why
24 pages later and i hope i did a good
enough job conveying that point it may
not be your reasons but they're most
definitely mine but the moment i stepped
outside i knew new vegas was going to be
different but i never expected that to
be a good thing obsidian did an
incredible job making this game some
have even claimed it's nothing short of
a masterpiece and to an extent i'm
inclined to agree it should serve as a
blueprint for not only how fallout games
can be made but how rpgs can be made
it's a wonderful game that's a part of a
wonderful franchise from 2012 when i got
my first achievement to 2021 as i'm
writing the last few pages of this
script i've never forgotten the fun i've
had with this game and i don't think i
ever will
if you've gotten this far in the video
thank you this video took a lot longer
than expected but i hope it was worth
the wait we're not done with fallout
trust me we got tons more to talk about
so stay tuned for that if you're new
here and want to see more essay videos
like this i encourage you to check out
some of my other videos like the ones on
screen or if you want a fallout video i
have both a fallout 3 and 76 video
available for your viewing pleasure as
usual like and subscribe if you enjoyed
today's video and if you're a returning
viewer i thank you for coming back
take care everyone
goodbye
[Music]
bye